so Peter we're here to discuss Bob Mo
Shay's but good for the money and I
thought it was the most no-holds-barred
account of the crisis I've read he is
not playing nice at a time when so many
other crisis memoirs are marred by
people's continuing needs extinct to get
along I also thought it was an amazing
story of leadership so so tell me why
did why did you want to do this book
well it actually started Bethenny with
my wife who at the time was an AIG
employee she was she was one of she
wrote a lot of Bob's the letters to
employees in the communications
department and Bob reached out to her
wanting someone to tell his story he
loved the way she wrote and I
subsequently became intimately involved
in the in the piece as well
it needed I think some outside
perspective someone who didn't know the
company so well at the beginning and
could come in and I was thrilled by the
idea of penetrating this man's mind
because I heard so much about him from
Val who really admired him she's worked
for many companies big companies
Citibank
Citigroup among them and she greatly
admired his leadership there was a
tremendous devotion within this company
to him and so finding out the story of
how this man turned this company around
and paid back the country 180 billion
dollars was just too delicious a
possibility I want to come back to that
I wanted to read this from the New York
Times obituary about when he decided to
take the job running AIG which is after
the crisis and when it looked like the
company was never going to recover and
when the AIG Board comes to him my first
response to them was you must think I'm
crazy but then I thought about it and
said to myself you know they're right
the financial industry is in chaos and
I've got the skills and the obituary
went on to say the drama and self-regard
were typical mr. Benoit che a
larger-than-life executive who was also
an imposing physical presence at six
foot floor not only did he restore AIG
to health by 2012 but he also repaid its
entire debt to the American taxpayers in
return 22 billion to them in profit as
well
it's a remarkable
of all achievement I was thinking about
this even this morning Bethany he was
the only person who thought this was
possible essentially I mean the
government didn't think this was going
to happen
the company certainly didn't think it
was going to happen they were ready to
sell it off for spare parts and
certainly the American people had no
expectation that this was going to
happen so that idea that he was a little
crazy I mean it you had to be a little
crazy to take this on and he was the
right kind of crazy he he did he was
approached earlier about the job when
they when they chose his predecessor ed
Liddy eventually but I think he was
spoiling to do it I think he really the
idea of taking this on just appeal to a
guy like this who who really was a guy
who got stuff done in in in the
corporate world I want to come back to
that but what did you what did you think
when you met him what stood out about
him when you when you met him talks
about the first meeting the first time I
met him we met in and I was immediately
struck by what a people person he was if
my idea of a CEO was someone reserved
and kind of arrogant and and had some
kind of some level of of not yeah
arrogance would be the word I found him
the opposite he was immediately
accessible he was funny he he wanted his
story told obviously in the mere fact
that he picked my wife as the first
person he wanted to tell it to endeared
me to him and he he wanted it told
honestly Bethenny he didn't want a piggy
ography he didn't want his story to seem
just the story of someone who was
flawless as a human being or as an
executive but who had tremendous
tremendous desire to tell the American
people and correct the record of of
their perception of the company so when
I immediately liked him I you he was the
kind of man who you had you asked him a
question he didn't think about his
answer he just gave his answer it was
like all what you saw was what you got
plus the fact that using charming and
handsome you could see well the
Karisma it was it was palpable in the
room in his office and so that was it
was an immediate like there was an
immediate enjoyment of him this is not a
guy who came from privileged in the book
he talks about working as a coca-cola
truck driver and being in the army
tell us about his early childhood and
how it shaped him the one of the
critical moments in his life Bethany was
at the age of 10 he grew up in the
Catskills his family ran a motel or a
bar and grill actually and eventually
had plans to open a motel they rented
out some rooms at this bar and grill and
at the age of 10
his father died suddenly of a heart
attack and the the really poignant part
of the story was in turn financially
anyway was that he left the family with
a quarter of a million dollars in debt
this is a 1953 or so 15 million dollars
really not something I really meant
something and his mother had no idea
what she was going to do so I this this
this led to the feeling that Bob had was
always on intimate terms with dead the
concept of debt and the end the the
desire his mother had to pay back that
that obligation which she never wavered
from and eventually did pay it back
extraordinarily and the reason that also
changed his life was because he had to
become intimately involved in their
business at a very young age he was the
oldest son and his mother leaned on him
very heavily in that business so that
instilled in him a real sense of of
commitment and responsibility I think it
at a young age he was also you know he
was a really independent kid he he
wasn't a perfectly behaved young man had
to do his things his own way and but but
always worked I mean and always wanted
to make money
he often said all through his life that
the motivating factor for what he did
very often was making money that meant
the value of money was extremely
important to him so that's why he always
had a job whether and
and learned about workers at the sort of
the ground floor level he there was
there was no trust fund there was no
extra boost by a relative to give him a
job never so by the time he was in the
army he he had he had inculcated this
very strong sense of of of earning a
buck so tell us about their - their due
to stories about his mom well they're
more than - in the book but they're -
that stood out to me in particular one
is a story you give them the pend tell
us about that one well they they owned
this motel in in Monticello New York and
he would sometimes work behind the desk
his mother was an incredibly pragmatic
woman Lillian and one day he was behind
the desk and a couple came up and they
asked about a room and he proceeded to
describe to them the options they had
for what they could rent for and what
the what the price was and and he after
the transaction was done his mother was
furious with him and he said what why
what's the matter she said son you
didn't give them the pen and he said I
don't know what you mean by that
she said when they're asking about the
room you describe what you you want them
to rent and you hand them the pen so
they can sign for the room don't let
them make the decision you make the
decision just give them the pen and this
became sort of a mantra for him an
understanding of what the transaction in
sales actually was you had to effectuate
the sale yeah you had to make it happen
the other one I loved that his mom told
him when he was complaining about being
bored in an early job you got a better
job No then go do it and talk about how
that shaped his philosophy this idea
that you you made you don't you you live
the handi were down exactly you you you
play the hand that's dealt you very
important if you find something better
do that but for the time being his her
philosophy always was son whatever is
available to you right
now is the thing you've got to go for
that was essential to him and it plays
out later in his in his career he was
always on the verge of another job
something that possibly he wasn't even
perfectly qualified for but he knew that
he had to take the leap he knew that he
had to go for it because that's what was
being dealt him I also loved this that
he talks about his leadership lessons he
says they are not the lessons of the
business school variety I've never been
to one never in fact enrolled in a
single business class ever these are
less ideas gleaned from a life and
business with an emphasis as much on the
life part of the business so to talk
about that a little because I think in
this day and age of expensive Harvard
MBAs his his approach and his training
were really interesting yeah he didn't
really he had no particular interest in
in schooling he went as a high school
for high school he was sent as a as a he
worked actually it was like almost a
work-study thing at a New York military
academy in fact was one year ahead of
Donald Trump at this school he didn't do
particularly well grade wise ever in
fact in college he went to Alfred
University which he'd never heard of
when they recommend that he go and he he
decided on his major math because he
thought that's what smart people would
major in not particularly I mean he had
some facility for numbers but his grades
were abysmal he had no interest in
studying matreya Lee wasn't
book-learning wasn't his thing at all
and I think he respected education it's
just that everything he gleaned was was
not from a book it was from the hands-on
experience that started when he was a
young man working for his mom so he
describes himself
well it's interesting today there's a
program people were telling me about
called GTD which is getting things done
and it's supposed to help you optimize
your time and Bob described himself in
the book is a GSD person so what is GSD
and how did it define him GSD is
the there's a Pajar there's an epithet
in there we'll just say it's get stuff
done okay and he was very very early on
in his career he was pegged as the get
stuff done done guy and what that was
was this remarkable facility he always
had for coming into a situation being
able to analyze it and even if he didn't
have the skills that that job required
finding them he was remember he came up
through operations in early days of
information technology and data
processing it's really where he got his
he cut his teeth and he always was the
man the person that that his higher-ups
could go to with a very challenging new
situation that required him to figure
out something that he didn't know before
and he knew how to Marshall people that
he needed to help him figure those
things out at Paine Webber he came into
a situation with knowing very little
about cash management accounts they were
behind the industry in creating those
remember those were those those those
those those accounts that that became
very essential for places like Merrill
Lynch and and penguin Burr and within a
very short period of time mastered it
and in fact figured out aspects like
marketing market research things he knew
very little about going in but knew how
to find the people that needed to
instruct him he was just a really quick
study that way so that GSD stuff
continued you know on and on through all
the jobs he had going into MetLife where
he took on the this huge responsibility
for D mutualization taking the company
public and I think that that was sort of
an operating a talent of his that just
got more in intense as he got older so
there are a lot of epithets and that's
very true to how he spoke and his voice
really comes through itches which is a
great testament to that to the writing
of the book but he has another phrase
and we probably won't be able to say
this one but he describes if there's
anything I love yes you rights it's the
business person who looks at you with a
pasted on smile spouting the company
line are nodding and completely
unconvincing
agreement so he has an expression for
that that maybe you can come up with a
way to describe and tell is tell me how
he thought about it he called it grin
effing and it's it it I mean it was
probably Bethany one of the reasons I
wanted to write the book I helped him
write the book because it was so
colorful and so perfectly a perfect
distillation of everything I've observed
over my life in in and we're in my work
life that I thought well here's a man
who's sort of a natural philosopher and
of course refers to people who smile at
you and nod in agreement and lavish
praise on you you you being the person
in charge to make you feel secure and
everything you're saying is brilliant
but in in fact walks away and goes what
a jerk you know this guy you know he
thinks he knows what he's talking about
we've all met them and Bob part of his
emotional intelligence Bethany was he
could he could suss that out in people
he knew the first time he met them
whether or not he was being grin EFT or
nod it was an amazing sort of intuition
that he had and I was actually thrilled
when I after I met him that you know I
certainly didn't want him to have that
impression of me even before I heard the
term and somehow you know Bob accepting
you into his world was a real badge of I
think of honor because you know he
recognized immediately when he was being
when he was being talked to and and not
in a honest way so one of the things I
thought about as I read this he does
talk about emotional intelligence and he
clearly cares a lot about employees but
he also talks about his own transparency
about being exactly who he is and he
quotes someone saying about him you need
somebody who will not be afraid to say f
you and I and I need everybody and that
that's the way he has how do you balance
those qualities because I think that
that the balance in those things is is
what's hard to achieve we meet a lot of
people who aren't afraid to say exactly
what they think but they trample over
everybody else and he seemed to have
something that prevented that a little
bit
I think it probably varied on the
audience I do think that he was kind of
if Bob was angry it was terrifying
he has a I hit a very very strong point
of view and didn't really I don't I mean
I think he wanted some debate but
ultimately I think he was so sure of
himself and what he wanted to do in most
situations that he didn't want the
challenges that we're going to thwart
him in any way or change his course and
to that point about balancing you know
he had tremendous charm and and I think
the key for him to running this company
and and what was extraordinary about his
ability as a leader was that he
understood and I think truly empathized
with the people who worked for him and
he wanted them to feel that he had an
ability to communicate that and you know
in I think he was I often said he was
more himself in front of a large group
of people than even was one-on-one
something came out of him there was a
performance aspect to Bob but it was
also very real I think he loved the idea
of taking people into his confidence in
large groups and they responded to that
the employees of AIG felt he truly
thought about them that's an
extraordinary skill for a CEO because we
all know we've all you know anyone who's
worked in a large organization knows
that the person the top is usually very
remote spares his appearance or her
appearances you know just for the sake
of control
the to it to a minimum Bob you know one
of the exchanges so so that gave him
tremendous capital with people and I
think for those moments when he was also
being Bob and being angry you know when
he came into a room and and and and told
off the people who work for him that
they were not doing well it had even
more power because they wanted to please
him they weren't just afraid that we
lose their jobs they they I think they
really wanted him to be happy because he
made them happy it was an exchange it's
an amazing balance he could strut
that way and from a leadership point of
view it's a very counterintuitive book
in some ways because today the mantra
and the thing you hear all CEOs say is
that they listen to all opinions in the
room and they want to take everybody
else's point of view into account and it
sounds like he did that but in the end
he ultimately wanted it to be his
decision absolutely I think that's true
I think that's totally true but that's
because in especially in the case of AIG
he had a he had a mission he knew what
the mission was he I mean he could he
had to you know shift the mission
because let's face it there were other
very strong people involved in this
process as well one particularly the the
chairman of the board and so he had to
he had to be a negotiator that way but
he knew as I said he relied so much on
his own sense of the value of things and
the value of people and felt he knew it
so well that he didn't really need you
know a colloquy constantly he didn't
need to have us a brain trust that that
told you know that told him the opposite
I think he that that drive really did
serve him incredibly well that that
intuition
so getting to AIG what did you know vig
you've had him you had a better
understanding of it given that your wife
worked there but what did you refresh
the audience as to why AIG matters well
the AG was the largest insurance company
in the world it had a it had it had been
dominated for decades by a legendary
leader named Hank Greenberg who had
built it into this conglomerate
Elizabeth Warren famously called it a
Frankenstein monster of a conglomerate
because it had it had so many working
parts but it was a trillion-dollar
enterprise that covered every part of
the globe was a very what I knew about
it was most seductive to be about the
company was its adventurousness in terms
of what it insured it had encrypted
mappings and and and and military things
I mean all kinds of high-risk claw
customers all over the world and and and
it it really did
change the nature of what a big
insurance company could do I think and
so that was my whole understanding I
didn't know anything about the
operations of the company I didn't
understand the workings at all and how
it how Byzantine it really was and how
much it was broken into little fiefdom
especially after Hank left in in the
mid-2000s so I I didn't an insurance
let's face it Bethenny is not the most
it's not the sexiest business on the
planet if you mentioned in some ways was
a very glamorous company even the name
though AIG didn't have much American
international it sounds so vague and so
it's almost like sounds like that you
know what you in a James Bond movie what
you name the company that you know
somebody was running you know it has
that sort of that vague quality so I
didn't really have a great understanding
and I think that was part of the problem
that the company had when when the dam
burst because I think the American
people particularly knew you know what
Citigroup was and what they don't you
know goldman sachs was and then lehman
brothers even layman brothers even um
but they didn't know much about this
insurance company it had a very foggy
public image so AIG became really the
poster child one of the most I think if
not the most hated recipients of the
government bailout and it was 187
billion right but but one of the big
controversies of the financial crisis
was this idea that a chunk of the money
that was funneled through AIG actually
went to bail out its counterparties on
all these credit default swaps big firms
like Goldman Sachs who received payment
in full for the these risky deals that
they had done with AIG so talk a little
bit about how Bob felt about that he was
furious it infuriated him that that they
were being bailed out at a hundred cents
to the dollar it made no sense to him
and he called them vultures he felt and
then and then it was you know
additionally there were they were all in
the building I mean they were
you know they were reaping hundreds of
millions more in consulting fees you
know they were all brought in to do
studies there was a huge plan called
project destiny which cost you know
untold millions that was supposed to
sell off the company very quickly into
its continued contingent parts and that
all drove him nuts he thought it was
unconscionable that they got paid off
before the public did it's interesting
he sounds like he was he ended up
running a firm that in some ways
epitomized Wall Street but yet he was
not of Wall Street and in fact a tone of
contempt toward the institutions that
that are toward our country's powerful
institutions from McKenzie took the
consulting firm to goldman sachs
permeates the book yeah I mean he had
some and he felt there were some fair
dealers you know there were some that
were you know fairer than others
he understood the nuances there and he
had friends on Wall Street but when it
came to AIG and what he wanted to do he
saw it very black-and-white he
understood that there was you know that
that something was amiss but there are
only so many fronts on which he could
fight at any one time before we come
back to project destiny talk a little
bit about who who Hank Greenberg was and
then what Bob's relationship with him
well Hank when when you know Bob had
been the CEO of MetLife in the 90s and
in early 2000 so they were competitors
and Bob had great admiration I think I
think he had great respect for what Hank
did at AIG I at AIG I think he thought
he was a visionary and knew him as a
competent competitor and and and just
the same way Hank had tremendous respect
for Bob thought that he shepherded
MetLife through a very difficult time
and so there was a there was a symbiosis
there was a connection that they had
Hank left under difficult circumstances
having to do with the Attorney General
of New York it's a long story it's still
am sorted story but he and Bob it was
Hank was one of the people who when
when the government and ahe we're
looking for a new leader after had Liddy
resigned he was one of the people aging
the government to look at Bob and they
had they had some meetings over time Bob
respected Hank I think he thought that
AIG was too big he came to the
conclusion that they had created
something that really wasn't it was
untenable I mean what Bob would say was
that Hank had created a company so you g
only Hank understood it so by the time
that Bob came along there he knew that
there had to be some you know sensible
reduction in the size of the company and
and he I think he over time continued to
want Hank as a as a sort of a silent
ally I wanted him to be someone who
supported at least but I think that's
because Bob thought he was a really
smart businessman so Bob comes into this
company this company that's on a
lifeline from the US government it's
incredibly controversial it's getting a
blame for the financial crisis you can
even argue a disproportionate share of
the blame for the financial crisis talk
about what he encountered in terms of
what was going on with the employees
when he got there the widespread hatred
toward a high G employees mostly because
of what was happening in one small unit
that created all the chaos AIG financial
products in which was in Connecticut and
London this was the home of the CDOs and
the credit default swaps and all that
that goods that horrible stuff those
people were were the focus of a
tremendous amount of American anger
particularly because of this issue
around the bonuses that they were
contractually entitled to but it played
out in the press so virulent ly there
was such animus towards these bonuses
became sort of the symbol of everything
that was wrong with it was actually not
that much money I mean you know
considering the billions of billions
that people
the government now had invested in AIG
it was something on the order of 60
million I can't remember the number but
anyway it it was a focus focal point for
the anger it got to the point where
organiz organized groups went and
protested at the homes of financial
products executives and workers there
were threats against death threats
against people in the company there were
security people had to be hired
I mean it was it was extreme it was way
over the top and it got to the point
where you know a IG took its name off
its building yeah it started creating
things like Chartists the the the
Property and Casualty
a company that that didn't want any
association with the name AIG I mean
that's and people wouldn't even wear
their identity their ID their ID tags
anymore yeah another thing to be you
know wildly angry about he he felt it
was and he felt that it was Congress and
even the president who fed the anger
that they that they in their statements
they might even some of them might be
privately much more conciliatory but
publicly were condemning and using
language that just inflamed the
hostility and made everybody's job in
Bob's opinion harder you know the
government was was was wanted a edgy to
pay back this money and at the same time
was basically telling t believes it was
a disreputable organization it made no
sense so on that level but it was mostly
because he couldn't believe that he had
an outsize amount of empathy for his own
people but you can understand you know
he felt responsible for these people he
says about Congress they seemed intent
on a strategy of corporate sabotage yes
exert and he you know he would watch as
there were these you know these things
would unfold like there was a you know
congressional hearing about a retreat at
the st. Regis Hotel in California that
cost at you know plus this is some
amount of money but it was a
was a retreat for sales promotion that
had been organized you know two years
before any of these things happened any
of the the so and had nothing to do with
the operations of financial products
this was in a an insurance division but
it became another huge public issue was
the the idea that you know that AIG was
sending executive still sort of robbed
at a at a California resort and you know
costing the taxpayers money but it was
you know you have as Bob wood said you
know you have to spend money to make
money so that again it all became a game
of of
you know who's the devil and portraying
the company is somehow a corrupt and
this this made him furious as the word
but nonetheless he does something pretty
remarkably hands-on for a CEO in terms
of those bonuses because there was a
huge demand from Congress to get the
bonuses back right and so what does what
does Bob do well Bob eventually decides
to get the money back himself it was it
had to do with Ken Feinberg who was then
what they're calling the pay czar he was
he was in charge of setting the salaries
for the top executives at all seven tarp
companies those are the Troubled Asset
Relief Program companies the ones that
got the money from the from Treasury and
what he did was what he called what's
called you know a clawback he promised
Feinberg in return for allowing them to
set executive conversation fairly at the
company he promised to get the money
back and he sat at his desk and what he
called dialing for dollars he picked up
the phone he got the list of the FP
people who had taken bonus money and
over a period of time got all the money
back through what through various you
know persuading by the way it is that he
did it himself that's but that's who the
man was that's who this man was talk
about his attitudes toward pay and
toward unpopular things like corporate
jets and
and CEOs being paid a lot of money his
predecessor as Liddy famously took $1 a
year to serve as a IG as cleanup guide
what was Bob's attitude about oh he
wasn't working for a dollar that for
sure he he valued his his skills and he
set a high I mean what he would consider
a reasonable price for his skills I mean
he got a package when he when he came to
AIG
he negotiated a package about 10 million
dollars a year at the time you know the
government was was setting it way lower
thought the ceiling for for a
compensation but the government also
knew they needed him you know one
important thing here to remember Bethany
is you know who was going to do this job
I don't think they had many really smart
alternatives to Bob and and set and also
Bethany someone who believed that this
could be achieved remember there was
nobody who thought this could happen
Bob truly did you know what price I mean
ultimately it was a very small price for
the for the American people to pay to
get this done and remembering also that
Bob had nothing to do with the damage
that had been done he came in to fix it
so when he did come in he knew that
compensation and this had this goes back
all through his career again you know
the the the importance of money to him
it was was very central he didn't do
this because he did it partly because he
wanted the American people to be made
whole he was a patriot but I think also
he wasn't gonna do it if he wasn't you
be paid and it took them a long time
even after it was the the agreement was
set on his salary for the it took
several months a couple of months at
least before he was paid the corporate
jet was also I think a very important
symbol for him it it had a terrible PR
impression for people partially because
the year before when the executives of
the three big auto companies came to
Washington to talk about their bailouts
they flew in on corporate jets it it
left a really bad taste in everybody's
mouth
but Bob felt that the jet was an
extension of his ability to do his job a
vital part of it remember it's a goal a
global company everywhere around the
world and they they had very specific
guidelines in the in the from the
government about how much it could be
used which basically made it almost
impossible for him to use it and drove
him crazy that comes through right I
mean he he was remember this guy who was
retired when he took this job on he had
a very happy life in this beautiful
place in Croatia and Dubrovnik
he loved growing you know grapes there I
know it sounds sort of elitist to people
but he liked I think just the you know
the it wasn't so much about like just
sipping fine wines he really loved the
process and the people there he got
incredibly close to the winemakers these
who I actually met these tough earthy
people who eat out a living you know
growing grapes on the sides of hills in
lepellier such peninsula he might make
even the most die-hard skeptic think
twice about corporate jets I have to go
okay so we have this meeting with Tim
Geithner before then the secretary of
the Treasury before he takes the job but
it's supposed to be a nice meet and
greet tell us what happened instead it
was a fiasco
Jim Milstein who is probably the other
hero of this the the other main hero of
this book he was the restructuring chief
for Treasury and it was very fortuitous
for the country that these two men
formed an alliance Jim was his biggest
booster and also though he was he was
the recipient of the most grief when Bob
did things that the government was sort
of terrified by in terms of
outspokenness and and and and iconoclasm
but Jim had recruited Bob essentially
they had meetings and and and advocated
him getting the job and Bob said you
know what Jim before I take this job
this is in the summer of 2008 before I
take this job I want to meet who really
is making the decisions
and Jim said I'm happy to have you I
want to go to Washington to meet them he
Bob didn't really want to deal with
Washington once he got the job but he
wanted to know who he was dealing with
so he went the Jim arranged for him to a
day to meet Milstein and Larry Summers
who was then oh one of Obama's his chief
economic adviser one of them and brought
him into a meeting which was supposed to
be a grin effing session between a
Geithner and and who had also been a
little bit leery of Bob to begin with
apparently was not sure he was the right
fit because of his outspokenness his his
his reputation for it and they sat down
and instead of having this kind of like
orientation session Bob read him the
riot act
he basically lectured Geithner about how
dare the government treat my employees
this the employees of AIG this way you
know you're not gonna get anything done
if you're if you're if there's threats
to people it basically told him off in
the session and Geithner was furious
apparently and the furious as the is the
theme of the of the hour he was really
angry and and Millstein took him out of
the room and said to Bob what what are
you doing what why would you do that Bob
said I just want him to know what I
thought that's and I think it was really
a test for Bob of how far he was gonna
be allowed to go number one and number
two it was a statement of independence
it was a declaration of independence
you're not gonna have a guy in this job
who's just gonna take phone calls from
you and do what you tell me to do he had
a better session with Larry Summers
after that went over there and by the
time he'd gotten over to Summers office
apparently it had gotten word to summers
that it had not gone well in Geithner's
office but summers believed in Bob to I
think very strongly and explained to him
some of the nuance the political
backstage were stuff that was going on
and why there had to be so much vitriol
aimed at AIG publicly even if they
wanted him to do a job but right a NAPA
motive somebody like Bob Wright
that's it you got it yeah he didn't like
that kind of you know you know he the
wonderful thing about Bob is that when
you read his his his town halls with his
employees his interviews with reporters
it's the same story as he tell us
privately there's no there's no you know
subtext it's all text so I was
struggling as I read the book to figure
out who he liked least and the Geithner
becomes a relatively minor character and
in the book but Geithner McKinsey the
press or Harvey God it was just people
described it as oil and water these were
two very strong men very talented men
very bright men but both had a vision of
leadership that they were and that they
were central it seems in cording to Bob
and it became during Bob's first year
Harvey came on almost simultaneously
with Bob and for the first time in the
company's history the job of CEO and
chairman and chairman was divided
between two people
Bob had mixed feelings about this
decision but ultimately thought you know
what if Harvey if the Chairman comes on
and we'll deal with the Washington stuff
that's fine I will deal with the company
I will deal with figuring out when we
sell off portions of the company I will
deal with morale building I will deal
with with with value here of how we're
going to enhance the brands over time
though they really never formed a
relationship I I do think it was the one
blind spot that Bob had that he didn't
really establish and he had so much else
on his plate it's sort of understandable
there was just endless amounts I mean he
was dealing most of his time with
compensation issues you know the you
know with the government for the first
several months of his jump but it
something never connected between those
two men and they both had visions of the
company that never were reconciled and
and Harvey held sway with the boat with
a lot of the board members
Bob's tendency to speak his mind
unnerved a lot of people and there
became a kind of what in Bob's mind
anyway a campaign to undermine him in
the
he had his theories about where it's
came from he told a famous story he'd
love to tell the story of somebody who
went to a doctor and the doctor said the
good news is you're not paranoid the bad
news is they're after you you know it's
like you know and that was his sort of
his the way his way you know he saw
wheels within wheels he saw the way
things worked and there were times for
example right after he took over the job
he had long promised he was going to go
back to Croatia for the harvest of his
first Zinfandel grapes and he had told
the government he had told the board he
felt he'd got signed off on that and
then when he went two weeks after he
started at the company all hell broke
loose when stories ran that he was here
here this company was you know
foundering and he's out you know the
happy grape Harvester you know I mean
they have pictures of him walking and
and it was like Milstein even called him
over there and said what are you doing
because he was giving interviews to
European report European reporters for
some American news organizations and
he's you know he was explaining that you
know these were catches catch can they
were putting them all together in
stories as if he was giving long
interviews and the IMP rate was a it was
a PR disaster
there's the showdown with Harvey on
Bastille Day right yes what happened
well they went back and forth that
really all crystallized over the deal to
sell the largest unit that AIG wanted to
get to divest itself of which was aia
which was a Chinese based insurance life
insurance company a huge crown jewel of
AIG is part of the original vision of
the company of a company that preceded
it by founded by Cornelius Starr in the
late that 1919 I think and Bob had
secured a what he thought was a coup in
getting getting a huge amount of money
from a British insurance company for the
for that for a ia that was way over what
the original valuation was by other
people at the company and the deal was
was not it didn't do
that well over time it looked like the
calm Prudential LLC PLC didn't have the
not related to the American Prudential
didn't have the the resources to make it
happen but it really brought the the
factions to a to a head on the board and
after the the board refused to back Bob
on a lower valuation for the company to
still sell it to try to sell to
Prudential it the relationship was in
tatters and at a meeting in that July
2009 Bob decided that you know it was
either he or Harvey who was gonna have
to go and he had talked about leaving
before he had another famous saying that
he thought he had something called fu
money and that was very important for
anybody to have in life because it
allowed you to walk away from from a bad
situation and he decided that that at
this meeting he was going to announce
that you know one of us has to go and
Millstein described it as the most
dramatic board meeting he has ever
attended
that's the restructuring guy over the
course of that afternoon at the debate
ensued with Harvey in his office and Bob
in his and the board wrestling with the
question of where this company was going
to go and who was going to lead it it
might have been a foregone conclusion at
that point that bob was the person who
had to do it they were so far down the
road with his plans that it would have
made no sense to lose him and Bob
probably knew that at some level
nevertheless at some point in that
meeting in that afternoon Harvey went
into Bob's office and said I think we
have to repair our relationship and Bob
said however we don't have a
relationship it's it's you know you can
imagine this incredible scene between
these guys with so much on the line here
and to his credit Harvey conceded at
that meeting he said no I'm gonna be the
one that goes and Bob still sitting in
his office waiting for the result to be
announced to him
walked over about an hour later after
the meeting had broken up and everyone
was gone I didn't know if he had a job
or not he didn't know and he had to ask
us I think it was a secretary he said
you know what happened you know in this
ad well they're they've left he ended up
calling Milstein on the phone who was on
his way to there's a daughter at camp
and no sign said no yards god there's a
new CEO Steve Miller and you're I mean
knew what chairman of the board Steve
Miller and you're the CEO by January
2011 AIG is really his company and this
is when the loans are paid back Neil
Cavuto says it's a comeback that is
nothing short of breathtaking but in the
meantime something has happened to Bob
he's found out he has he has cancer and
did he do what some people might do and
cut back on work and yeah that was an
extraordinary moment and I only met Bob
after he was already diagnosed and being
treated for cancer so his you know his
whole persona was was somewhat informed
by that but that that month in October
of 2010 he had been coughing and went to
a doctor and ultimately an NYU his one a
wonderful oncologist that he had Abraham
Joshua Joshua they informed him that he
had lung cancer and he was going to go
on a treatment regiment they were they
went they went through a treatment
regimen they were going to decide which
which one to do and on the debt there
was actually an important meeting to set
the price of AIA on the day that
happened he was having chemo and NYU and
he was on the phone he had not told
anybody in the company yet I believe
that this was happening and he told NYU
this is a regimen he was supposed to
take over several days but he didn't
have time for the chemo to be
administered over several days so he had
he said you've got to give it to me all
at once
so he sat for hours and hours he had I
think it was three I don't know I mean
remember how many actual were the
regimens were compressed for the one
sitting but it it was a terrible ordeal
for him in part because he was terrified
suddenly would think that would be
confronted by mortality obviously the
personal pain was intense for his family
but also the idea suddenly that he
wasn't gonna get this job done that he'd
invested so much of himself in it that
that was you know alarming in to the
core of who he was the other interesting
question was how much do you disclose
what do you tell who do you tell when do
you tell and what would that how would
that affect he he was worried that they
would usher him right out the door that
it would be okay this guy's done we're
not you know we're gonna have to go with
somebody else he ultimately decided
shortly thereafter to tell the board and
and the press and the company and the
people of the company that he had cancer
that it was being treated at which it
was at that point it was very iffy as to
what the outcome was going to be and but
he did not reveal that he had lung
cancer he never revealed it and you know
in light of Steve Jobs and his
pancreatic cancer which was another you
know it became an issue although that
was disclosed fairly early on it is kind
of surprising it is amazing that he was
able to keep that to him to basically to
himself he he didn't feel it was
anybody's business what kind of cancer
he had especially since he was in
treatment for it the prognosis at the
beginning was a year I think and he was
pretty I remember he had a conversation
Milstein he said Milstein asked him on
the phone he said are you gonna be
around to do this and Bob said well it
depends on how this works I hope I will
you know was that iffy and you know by
the grace of God he the the first
treatments he had were very very
successful and he didn't live a year he
lived four and a half years with various
into
vengeance that and he could he never
missed a day's work I thought it was
interesting what you said about his fear
of dying before this job was finished he
writes and it's a very poignant line in
the book I plan to work as hard as
possible to erase regret from my
vocabulary which shows you how important
this this this was to him so I got one
place perhaps where he didn't get it and
it's still something that's an issue in
our campaigns today and that has been at
least partly attributable Bernie Sanders
popularity right which is the continued
anger of the American people and Bob
just seemed to have no time for that he
wrote he wrote you know it was just
mistakes basically and that if we blame
people for their mistakes the entire
company would be in jail and he said you
know he's he doesn't he doesn't didn't
didn't fault the actions the nation took
but the blaming and the viciousness that
went on after the actions were were
taken what did you think about that he
compartmentalized it I think yeah I
think he really he really could he could
in his own mind I tried on many
occasions Val and I both as we talked to
him we tried in many ways to see to get
him to to talk about an understanding of
how much pain there was on Main Street
as a result of what happened and I I
don't think it was that he wasn't a
compassionate man I do think though that
he believed so strongly in what business
could accomplish the good that could be
done by by by business by by American
enterprise that that he had to almost
seal off the idea of the damage and the
not the damage so much as the reaction
the response you know it was like get
over it let's we're not there anymore
and I think that was key to how this all
happened I don't know that he could have
achieved this extraordinary result which
was paying back at a profit within three
years this massive amount of money that
even the Congressional Budget Office
said would never be paid off the
Government Accounting Office and none of
these organizations they would written
this company off as a 50 billion
or loss I don't think if he if he had
dwelled on the fact that that people
were hurting I don't think he could have
achieved everything he did to because he
thought of it as helping them stop
hurting and it's almost like I know you
want to shake him and say you wanted a
shake and say just say you know yes this
is you know criminal you know but he
didn't he didn't see it that way so it
underscores at this lunch he has with
President Obama after energy has made
its loans back so tell us about the
lunch well finally you know it was like
he often talked you know there was a
famous article about him
in New York magazine which had a great a
great sort of summarizing headline it
was a picture of a beaming picture of
Bob looking great looking robust you
know looking like I'm you know a great
American success story and over the head
the headline was you're welcome America
and he did feel as if the country did
not have much gratitude for what he and
the company had achieved in paying them
back you know it was all like it was all
in the negative column there was no plus
column so that was extremely upsetting
to him partly because he thought it
would so help the company to have an
acknowledgement of what it had done and
his whole thing was his legacy was going
to be leaving a healthy AIG was going to
be leaving this company as you know
proving the naysayers completely wrong
by making sure this company survived
beyond the payback and so Milstein
arranged for Bob to have a meeting with
Obama you know remember that he didn't
excuse me you know but bob was not a
huge fan of this administration I think
it's fair to say he felt some things he
admired about it but others he thought
that that Obama was not a forceful
enough voice on many issues including
the role of American business and I
think he was he thought it was cowardly
when Obama went after
FP I mean he thought that there was
something truly unfair about you you
know the the the platitudes that Obama
voiced trying to sort of like it almost
did encourage the he thinks the anger
towards the company so there was a meet
there was in January of eleven Milstein
arranged for Bob to go to the White
House to sit down for short meeting with
Obama and once again and you know in the
midst of this the pleasantries Bob laid
out what he thought was this you know
this lack of fortitude about American
business on the part of the president
and you know I I wish I could tell you
that I had you know great insight into
you know the the back-and-forth that
happened on that day but Bob left it at
that
Bob left it at his sort of instructing
Obama on on this issue and so you know
he was never gonna get a Presidential
Medal of Honor for his which I think he
actually deserved frankly for what he
did with this company but his heroism
was of a sort that didn't necessarily
mean the political establishment was
going to recognize it so you and he
right at the beginning of the book that
this is much life lessons as it is
leadership lessons and he writes in the
book which I thought was really
interesting I've discovered that it all
comes down to what you mean by happy the
reality of a working life is that ups
and downs occur in phases and nothing is
forever not even life itself what did he
mean by that well that's a great
question I mean I reflect on it now
hearing it back it's like I hear I can I
can hear him sort of you know thinking
about you know where his life had taken
him and you know I think he's his great
there was some regret Bethenny in that
you know he wasn't gonna ever get to
spend those those sort of sunset years
you know in this place he loved far away
from the United States in Croatia we
spent a lot of time with his family with
the people
he loved and you know there was that
sacrifice you know that he made you know
in spite of the fact that it gave him it
might have extended his life you know
just just having the this in his life
thirty just the the adrenaline who knows
you know I mean it but I think he was
deeply aware of the fact that you know
work can only make you so happy that
that was not the be-all and the end-all
I mean in spite of the fact that he was
you know a workaholic in many ways he
also had some perspective on it so he
had a complicated personal life how did
that affect your view of him that's a
great question we talked a lot about and
what we're describing here what we're
talking about here Bethany for readers
for audience members is that he had
relationships outside his marriage
particularly one very important one to
him he had been legally separated from
his wife for many years and had remained
very close to her it was it was a
complicated situation and it was it was
somebody who he worked with at admit
life and when he was CEO and so it's
it's it's not the it's not a life that's
tied up neatly in bows but whose life is
and we debated a lot we talked to him
very long and heart including with the
other people involved in the situation
about whether to include all aspects of
his life in the book it it had been
publicly known before so it wasn't a
complete surprise but he said it quite
powerfully and I included his
justification in the book and he said
I'm not a saint
I don't want people to think I was a
saint and I think that made him all the
more credible you know to be able to
share all that to let you know you know
heroes are flawed human flawed human
beings and and we we learn so much more
from people who have the Speck
term of experiences than we do from
someone who's just you know creates an
image for themselves that we're supposed
to believe in and we ultimately know it
we're alternately disappointed by those
people I think that's a really wise
observation and it really is a great
book so congratulations thank you it's
lovely talking to you about it